okay so in this video I want to begin
our discussion of lipid digestion and
absorption by starting off specifically
with digestion so we're gonna start off
out here with some dietary lipids
including mostly triglycerides as well
as some cholesterol cholesterol esters
free fatty acids and fat soluble
vitamins and they're gonna enter the
mouth and in the mouth there's no actual
digestion of lipids right so there's no
lipid digestion here okay in the mouth
so they're gonna continue on through and
enter the stomach where a few different
things happen
okay so let's scroll down just a little
bit okay so in the stomach we're gonna
have the the churning and mixing of the
ingested lipids and the whole idea there
is that the stomach's gonna kind of
shake around and move and mix things up
and that's gonna break up these large
globs or droplets of lipids into a bunch
of smaller droplets so we have this
large glob here and then mixing and
moving around of the stomach is gonna
make that into a bunch of smaller
droplets and that's important because it
increases the surface area for digestive
enzymes to act on and so it makes it
easier for things like lingual lipase
and gastric lipase in the stomach to go
through and digest triglycerides into
fatty acids and to munno's with Lister
also what's happening here is that these
triglycerides are having the ASO groups
on on carbons one in two of the glycerol
backbone being removed as free fatty
acids and then the rest of it ends up
being a mono a so glycerol a two mono a
so glycerol because the to me because I
a so group is on carbon number two and
so lingual lipase is named for the for
the glands at the back of the tongue and
gastric lipase is named for the glands
at the in the gastric mucosa now also in
the stomach we have the emulsification
of the keeping apart by dietary protein
so in addition to taking these large
blobs and turning them into these a
bunch of smaller globs so it makes it
easier for enzymes to act on we've got
to make sure that those those tiny
droplets stay apart from each other and
so that is done by dietary protein so
typically when a person eats a meal
they're not just eating lipids they're
usually eating with you know they're
usually
some carbs and proteins along with their
with with whatever it is they're eating
typically of course now when when
proteins reach the stomach the acid
it'll kind of denature um and they'll
kind of be freely flowing kind of like
polypeptides and those amino acids there
are some those amino acids that make up
those fly peptides are both polar and
nonpolar and so there's like this
hydrophilic hydrophobic separation that
allows them to interact with some of
these lipid droplets and when they do
that they kind of form a structure that
looks something like that this is just
kind of my visual but the whole idea
here is that the blue part there is is
protein that blue stuff there is protein
or denatured protein like polypeptides
and they're keeping apart those lipid
droplets so they don't come back
together and just form one of these
again okay so in addition to breaking up
that large glob let into a bunch of
small droplets we want to keep those
droplets apart so they don't come back
together okay and so that also of course
allows the enzymes to digest those lipid
droplets more read more readily more or
more easily also there's this idea of
gastric emptying so some of those
digested contents are going to flow with
the kind into the small intestine and
that's going to be done slowly from the
stomach the small intestine that's
important to allow proper subsequent
digestion and absorption in the small
intestine so the gastric emptying is
actually controlled is actually slowed
down specifically by cholecystokinin or
CCK in response to the lipids beginning
to beginning to reach the small
intestine which is next
you